hello and welcome to math simplified in
this video we will talk about the kreb
cycle
krebs cycle is also known as the
tricarboxylic acid cycle and it is a
biochemical pathway that is used to
generate energy to the oxidation of
acetyl-coa it is also used for the
synthesis of NADH and for the production
of amino acids
krebs cycle takes place in the
mitochondria of the eukaryotes and the
cytosol of the prokaryotes
the first step involved is actually a
preparatory step which begins with
pyruvate pyruvate is derived through the
glycolysis of glucose which is a six
carbon compound and it is split into two
molecules of pyruvate which is a three
carbon compound
the next step includes the oxidation of
pyruvate into acetyl-coa by the enzyme
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex and in
this reaction a molecule of carbon
dioxide and a molecule of NADH is
generated
the acetyl co a is a two carbon compound
in
the next step the acetyl co a combines
with oxygen as it eight which is a four
carbon compound to form citrate and
hence the resulting molecule is a six
carbon compound this reaction is
catalyzed by the enzyme citrate synthase
in
the next step the citrate is isomerized
in to isocitrate by the enzyme
akan it is
next the isocitrate is oxidized into
alpha ketoglutarate by the enzyme
isocitrate dehydrogenase and in this
reaction a molecule of nad is reduced to
NADH and a molecule of carbon dioxide is
generated hence the alpha ketoglutarate
is the five carbon compound since one
molecule of carbon is lost into carbon
dioxide next the alpha ketoglutarate is
converted into sixteen alkyl by the
enzyme alpha ketoglutarate dehydrogenase
and in this reaction also a molecule of
nad is reduced to NADH and
a molecule of carbon dioxide is released
hence the 16 algo a is the four carbon
compound in
the next step this sucks in Elko a is
converted into succinate
by the enzyme succinylcholine taste in
this reaction a molecule of gtp is
generated
neck succinate is
converted into fumarate by the enzyme
succinate dehydrogenase
in this reaction a molecule of qs2 is
generated which is used for the
production of fadh2
fumarate is then converted into malate
by the enzyme fume race
and
in the last step the malate is converted
into oxaloacetate by the enzyme malate
dehydrogenase and in this reaction also
nad is reduced to NADH
now let's look at the results of the
Krebs cycle
through each cycle of the krebs cycle
following products are generated three
molecules of nadh one molecule of fadh2
one molecule of GTP and two molecules of
carbon dioxide
now since glucose is split into two
pyruvate compounds
for each molecule of glucose this cycle
runs twice hence the products formed are
six NADH two fadh2 to
gtp and four carbon dioxide all the nadh
and fadh2 are next fed to the electron
transport chain for the generation of
ATP
so this was a short description of the
krebs cycle
thank you so much for watching this
video make sure to subscribe us on
YouTube for all the latest videos and
also make sure to follow us on Facebook
for the latest updates you can support
massively fight by buying on any
shopping website like flip card Amazon
eBay Snapdeal and many other sites to
the affiliate links given in the
description below whatever you buy a
small percentage of that will be donated
to met simplified which is used for
covering the cost of equipment softwares
and maintenance of this channel you can
also donate directly to met simplified
all links are given in the description
below